our next presenter appeared in a film
this year as an alien but he's certainly
no alien to Oscar
having won the Best Supporting Actor
Award in 1982 for an officer and a
gentleman here to present the Oscar for
Best Documentary Feature is Louis
Gossett jr.
the goal of most feature films is to
entertain the goal of most documentary
films is to enlighten documentary
filmmakers turn their camera on the
world and show us what's happening there
and bring us face to stream with reality
that documentary features which are
nominated for their excellence tonight
are broken rainbow Maria Florio and
Victoria mud producers las madres the
mothers of Plaza de Mayo
Susana Munoz for more base material
soldiers in hiding
yeah fat Asha producer the Statue of
Liberty
Ken Burns and buddy Squires producing
unfinished business
Steven Okazaki producer the winner is
broken rainbow
thank you this is a great great honor
and thank you for hearing the voices of
our Native American people on behalf of
Native people all over the world who are
at this moment fighting for their land
and their lives I thank you very much
for your support thank you for having my
people